it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gonna keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was bryan when it was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do it
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
this is how we do it this is how chain
does it die
guys this is how we do it first of all
it's wednesday morning hey i want to
thank everybody out there for telling me
how great i look all the time and
that's nice you know what i mean and all
i'm wearing is [ __ ] black t-shirts
and jeans simple i gotta shake it up a
little bit you were very colorful this
morning you showed up in a pair of
jewelry sunglasses
you got jewels around your neck
you got a tank top
showing off that
tank top oh it was the teeth new tee
them right down
you got some ripe delts kid
riped out like a stingray you know what
i call you when you're in a tank top
right
hungry eyes
hungry eyes your way around those uh i
think it was an actress remember yeah
and i pretty famous actress very famous
actress and i uh pretend not to eat
well they were they were eyeing the up
but good it was like they're hungry it
was like you got two kids and a giant
candy cane
walks in a giant candy cane with feet
comes in happy girls big fat dick
you know
keep going no i like where you're going
i don't mean to okay without the train
don't edit my [ __ ] story but no i
didn't say that but a candy cane with a
big fat thing no no i know you want a
big
a a tan
king
a respectable dick depends what we're
talking about
respectable dick right
it's good fine it's good may i continue
yeah sorry i just wanted you know
brown candy cane
i don't need you to [ __ ] juice it
edit my story i know just i just would
wish you'd say candy cane
juicy dick
he comes in and goes before the girls
were there he comes and goes i'm gonna
get two pieces of this pie because he
looked at me because he just i i just he
just goes down and goes that pie looks
nice that's pizza in the world that pie
looks nice you're talking about the
straight pie you're talking about
straight pipe i thought we were going uh
new york slang they had them we called
uh pizza pie in new york yeah yeah they
had a they had an apple pie
about three inches thick at least daddy
with that crust
the [ __ ] out of here with that crunch
cookie crust so daddy got a piece of the
apple pie and
three slices of the pepperoni you did
and you go you looked at me and the the
apple pie
they they got it all sitting up there
you know how when you know when you're a
little horny and then you you're an
instagram and some girl is on a stool
with her butt you know they'll do that
it'll be like just like oh let's see how
i can tap into the male lizard brain and
some girl's got this impossible butt and
side boob and she's just got her ass
hanging off a stool and she's like what
this little thing and every guy's like
you gotta pause a little bit and the
captain's a bible quote if your girl's
next to you you go i'm not gonna pause
because i'm on a plane and people behind
me can see i'm gonna keep scrolling or
are they quote like albert einstein i'm
like how dare you
how dare you drag steve jobs into yeah
the best is i can't believe the world's
on fire like this people are hungry it's
like oh it'd be that it's like save
ukraine it's like all right
that's right but they had that pie
basically set up the way your butt is on
a stool if you got if you got ass for
days and then he goes i'll get a pie he
goes maybe i should get two pieces i'll
get one piece i'll start one piece
and three two three pieces you got
excited you got pizza so you got three
slices you can't wait to [ __ ] this
gelena takeaway by the way best pizza
best pizza
i mean let's you know i love new york
you have great pizza
i've said it you're from new york no no
no it's you giuliana takes me tough to
beat i've eaten pizza everywhere in the
world everywhere me too naples naples
italy yep rome naples florida nichols
florida yeah
all of it rome georgia
i've eaten everywhere yeah new york
i've had some new york pizza i lived
there for eight years prince pizza right
up there very good pizza right there
right there top
1a1b julia takeaway jelena g
j e jelena g-j
h-e-l-i-a
jelena is spelled no g-j yes
g-j-e-l-i-n-a
best pizza on the planet the takeaway is
the pizza in the restaurant it's small
pan pizza it's from still good for kids
that's good the lamb pizza the pork
cheek the chocolate
the [ __ ] burrito
this is the crust daddy girls come in
gorgeous famous i say bro those guys
those girls are literally
whispering about you and looking at you
because you kind of knew one of the
girls she said hi to you yeah like and
then uh you go uh i go what are you
doing and he puts the pizza away and
wipes his mouth
and just stands there and you go why
aren't you eating it don't wait till
they leave
i don't want to look like a fatty really
yeah fat kid came out you ever seen mark
eat
i have zero self-consciousness it's
disgusting maybe i should i mean i don't
think you're aware of it it's literally
like the cookie monster but with like
lasagna no look people go like this
almost everyone who ever sees me eat
because it's a few different things i
mean sloppiness would be one vector but
also the speed at which i eat seems to
frighten people they're like
how many calories do you take a day in
the upper limit is very high i usually
do you know so it's like i only when
we're on the road and we go somewhere
it's like yeah you know but i may eat 10
thousand calories in a day but normally
like three thousand ten thousand yeah i
don't care but the but but when you eat
no one can but when you eat uh slow down
uh when you eat do you it's like you eat
like you're in the military like we're
rushing you yeah to go off the floor
yeah like your navy seal and it's like
you have like 20 like you know like
something there's no rush
did you grow up with brothers i did and
um
other people's i was like oh you guys
have a pantry like that's crazy like you
just have unlimited food
because like that's the gallon of milk
and i'm getting to it before you do so i
don't know but like no that's that's i
don't feel any self-conscious about it i
probably should because it immediately
reveals it's like oh this person didn't
grow up with money or whatever it says
there's nothing wrong with that no i
don't think yeah
it's very common when you have a big
family and food is not abundant yeah you
you get you're not getting seconds
unless you hurry up yeah so you're not
seeing so many like mark mike
i would say speed especially because
people will be like
maybe people could eat more in a contest
or something like that but as far as
pure speed i've never seen anything like
it yeah yeah never in my life like
didn't the kogi truck burrito like it's
a korean barbecue burritos you ate it my
friend even i got six of those in five
minutes without a drink like or i should
say my the bet was that i could eat six
i got the sixth one in my mouth but i
feel like you're not enjoying the food
that's sort of that's what bothers me
right you're not tasting i do because my
taste buds function but people i always
say that do like you know you're not
tasting the food i am and that's what
makes me want more of it
i know i could it's
for example when i go to a nice
restaurant like a french restaurant or
something i do i'll be like oh man every
bite is really good and i do know what
that feels like to do that um but
sometimes i feel like you like putting
away the food i'll be like oh [ __ ] i
need to pretend like i eat slow right
that's gonna say when you go on a date
is your girl like hey man yes it's
almost like you farting in front of a
girl's like oh now you know that i like
do these gross things i have enough
self-consciousness to be like if i'm
trying to impress somebody
i won't eat like a maniac but yeah um
it's the default marquee it's like jabba
the hutt on the road man
okay what what favorite meal what's your
favorite meal if you're gonna die last
meal oh i don't there's too much i love
the nice fillet am i still on car if i'm
gonna die no you can eat that [ __ ] off
you can eat it no but i won't look good
in the casket i'm gonna be all bloated
no dude come on no sodium
dude
you got it you can have anything you
want you're gonna a fresh pizza from
prince i'll drain your blood so don't
worry about it
uh i don't i don't know dude there's so
much food i [ __ ] love i don't you
don't know
just like all the food we've ever seen
is it pizza is it steak what is it uh it
might be the t-bone from uh scopa okay
the t-bone from scopa with the uh uh the
steak tartare
okay so a lot of meat red meat yeah
that's all i eat
but daddy's back in the car for two
weeks i got it dude i don't i don't be
bloated in the casket though hey [ __ ]
dude hey dude hey we put my dior shades
on when in the casket i don't have bags
in the magic man i'm getting annoyed now
what are you gonna eat how what dessert
are you gonna have dessert yeah bro you
get this i'll take your pazuki from um
bj's pizza house pazuki is you know what
i'll take
i'm glad you asked this is the fat kid
coming out of me and i'm on a diet so
this is triggering but i'll take two
warm
chocolate chip cookies from mrs fields
and then i want and i used to do this
when i was a kid weekly then i want
probably three inches of vanilla icing
in between really it's called a double
dozer what if i what if i push
a couple of voodoo donuts towards you
would you trade that in it just had
voodoo no no no uh miss field's uh
double dues in all day really you know
all day give me a cheat meal that's my
thing too sweet for me daddy can't even
with his teeth anymore but whatever yeah
could it help you go get your invisalign
you have to move your teeth around you
know what i called them and
send it up
okay sitting up i'm getting i'm getting
mad because because i'm i'm on the road
two weeks in a row and then when i get
back that is a little bit of break i'm
doing it then i set it up
i set it up i can't do it before that
ain't happening too busy i want you to
move your teeth around yeah i know okay
yeah because yours looks good
dude
i'm back on the trays okay because i
didn't wear them 22 hours a day 22 hours
it's a problem
and you and don't wear them 20 20 hours
a day because it's not going to work
and then and you'll be has to be twenty
two
six months in and you just double down
to 24 hours
yeah but then you can't eat with them
all right yeah drink drink your meals
put in a blender drink drink your drink
a steak
to get your teeth don't have that
discipline nobody does dude no
you take care of your body you take care
of your fashion you work out yay well
what about your brain what about your
state of mind your mental health people
forget about this dude a healthy brain
is everything but nobody wants an engine
to the body finding a good therapist
going to a therapist it's expensive it
takes time you got to wait in a room
that's why our friends have better help
dude online therapy it is cheaper than
in-person therapy better help is online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat only therapy sessions so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to or you can like i said
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy you can be matched with a
therapist a licensed therapist in under
48 hours it's important guys get your
brain right if your brain's right that's
working the engine you're going to get
to where you need to get we're talking
about professional online therapy
professional not your friends not your
family professionals all right and you
guys the farm kid listeners and viewers
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com fighter that's better
h-e-l-p-com
fighter
you know what i did last night you ever
finished a show and you're so [ __ ]
bummed out didn't i have nothing what
was the show uh bates motel
in uh my mother-in-law has been telling
me to watch it forever and she knows tv
so our buddy todd told me to watch it
and so i'm like all right all right fine
we gotta do it and it starts starts off
slow and then you're in it's five
seasons we finished last night i was
like [ __ ] it's like depressed man yeah
same with stranger things and then they
take so long come out like
then i get done with and i go down the
rabbit hole i look at you know them
breaking down you know all the
characters and like the shoot the behind
the scenes and all that
and they the director came out and said
you know we kind of got to move quicker
on this one
because they are supposed to be this age
so for instance a couple of the
characters in the episode they're
playing they're 17 18. but he goes
really currently right now they're like
30 32. so we can only do that for so
long so we can't wait too long to film
season five so i'm like oh dope this
coming uh you know normal kind of fast
time i don't have to wait too long
this dude said we won't start shooting
end of 23.
daddy ain't getting it to 2024 by then i
forget the plot
uh
it's like avatar two moved on dude
what's like avatar two or toy story four
10 15 20 years later
[ __ ] i've moved oh me too
i'm out
it's so there's too much too much
competition all right dude but miss the
bates hotel is good man yeah that kid's
so good who plays norman bates i don't
know why i'm so obsessed with the loan
i'm not i can't even figure out why i'd
rather be
here's a truth true statement i think
i'd rather be watching alone
over anything else in the world
sometimes wow and i think it's just
because i like seeing
how you survive and then i go to bed and
i fantasize about how i would do it but
it's the same time every time it's like
the first 48. all right it taps in the
prepper in me or some weird [ __ ] and
people suffer
it's so interesting and they sign up for
it oh i think they win 100 grand
listen to me
you you better be set in traps nets
lines
and have a bow and arrow you better be
doing everything yeah but the people
that go on that show be are like real
outdoors extremists and they still start
and they've done it but like they would
500 grand no camera crews no gimmicks
along the ultimate test i don't want to
see don't show me that they i i have
seven enough seven seasons to go oh they
still starve they still starve well yeah
but they also what's interesting is
this is their normal they do this on
their own time yeah they'd be like hold
on you give me 500 000. [ __ ] yeah do it
yeah one dude still out there had a
seven bedroom condo man i'm [ __ ] i
can't wear weeds
it was lit had electricity and [ __ ] damn
yeah do you guys wanna watch tv like
what the [ __ ] yeah
well they'll drop one dude just panicked
one dude in the first season they drop
he's a cop from arizona
not prepared and also learn about the
wildlife just learn about it he goes
black bears wolves cougars and more
black bear more wolves more cougars than
anywhere else in north america it's an
island it's i think it's vancouver
island and all they do is live there and
hunt all day like like they're like a
thousand cougars you can hear the wolves
and that's where he they planted it two
black bears the first night two black
bear all right
just sniffing around you know and uh
he's like i'm going home
he was out yeah he goes i'm going home
he calls up the next day he was home if
you like that i'm surprised you don't
like 60 days in i probably will do you
know what it is no it's literally normal
people that uh like maybe their family
member or something happen or a
correctional facility officer they've
never been inside prison so for 60 days
they have to go into jail like
jail jail like a nasty jail and they're
undercover
and so they the before they go in like
the you know the sheriff and the person
who runs you know the warden tell them
like you got to get your story straight
because when you're the new guy in there
they're going to ask you
why you're in here and it better be
[ __ ] air tight because they're going
to sniff it out and if they find out
that you're a plant
it's trouble like we got to get you out
of there yeah and then they all have a
sign like they go if you go up because
they know where the camera's at that the
the the crew is watching if you go up
there and you start rubbing your neck we
know to get you out there's a problem
so
there's one guy in there and clearly has
some issues but he was married i think
he had a kid he did 60 days thriving
he's never been to prison i think his
dad was in prison so he want to feel
like his dad went through so he's in
there for six days thrives everyone
loves him he's [ __ ] has friends and
they go six days up he goes i think him
and he has a little kid and a wife and
he goes i think i'm gonna stay another
60 days
do another 60.
thriving
because you know what let's stay another
60. you got 180 dude just [ __ ] move
in free free right i love hanging with
the guys yep and you got a kid bro yeah
what were you doing yeah yeah this is
the first time he's ever slept good yeah
you got a kid well he gets out after
whatever 80 180 days commit suicide oh
he did
dude if you missed it that bad just
committed a crime and get back in there
oh wait because he hated he hated being
in the real world i don't know clearly
he had some he had problems oh yeah
well even the producer like no the trial
is over dude you've succeeded you did it
he's like i'm just gonna stay a little
longer committed suicide committed
suicide yeah that's a guy who didn't he
was he would but you would like to see
things in because there are guys that
like they're in gangs and stuff oh here
we go he was charged with rape
oh
rape and assault okay
dies by suicide after being charged with
rape and assault yep that's him right
there okay and was it before he went in
he was charged no no no no days before
he left you can't book him on a [ __ ]
reality show if you're raping people man
well yeah you can't believe this is that
he left
prison so he gets out to that did he
rape somebody in jail
um
i don't think that's gonna do it but he
uh
the show the show if you if you like
like survival and stuff
b you would like this because there are
guys that when they grew up in like a
gang and again their fathers or friends
all went through the prison jail system
so they have one guy who was like a
leader of a gang he was like a shot
caller he got out of the gang but he
goes in prison he still has all the
prison tattoos
and he gets back in that lifestyle they
have to take him aside like dude bro
this isn't real because he starts
running [ __ ] some guy stoles from he
beats him up then he has guys working
for him he took the prison over he took
like the mexican cartel over and started
running [ __ ] and like we gotta get you
out of here jesus he's like nah i'm good
dude and like got way too into it
yikes one one guy because he played
college football he's like he was like a
super air games like this be easy three
days in getting his ass what yeah like
he said i wanna out yeah yeah it's it's
not one girl goes in she has a husband
next thing you know she has a girlfriend
it's it's fun but the show became so
popular that now the
the jig is up like they go in and people
go oh 60 days implant like you they'll
call it out now really so they got to
mix it up yeah i don't know what they're
doing now they mix it up
you've been seeing all the drama going
on with jake paul and connor no and
jake paul had his press conference with
uh rahman junior's uh
you know uh was haseem rahman who beat
lenox lewis right world champion so his
son is fighting jake paul now oh so jake
paul oh you don't have this narrative so
jake paul was supposed to fight tommy
fury right yes and they got canceled and
pushed twice why so tommy fury goes
oh my family can't come with me i can't
get a visa blah blah his dad who's you
know chatty kathy comes down and goes he
was in shape wasn't ready we told him he
could do if he wants but he's not in
shape so jake's like what the [ __ ] man
so then jake goes right i still have the
venue book math square garden which i
think is august 6 so i need a a a new
opponent so he decides to take on
hussein rahman jr who has already it's
100 yes he's very good
hold on dude he has a hundred amateur
fights over a hundred damage fights and
he's 12-1 as a pro oh and they've
they've sparred together before
and apparently uh rahman junior goes you
know i was told not to go hard on you i
used one hand
he was i know that was years ago and in
the press conference you would expect
jake to light him up
but i would say roman junior kind of won
this thing because he was like hey
i just got a question for you have you
learned how to box
you know what i'm saying like well it's
not a smart fight for jake no it's not
just jake's brother and manager was like
do not take this fight he's like i gotta
fight well jake really wants to be a
boxer but i mean that i r you got to
respect the kid for to because
that guy's going to hurt him if it's if
he's not careful careful
that's a real box how many fights
i mean over a hundred amateurs jesus
is a pro
is he a pretty big guy too if i fight
the heavyweight but this fights that
cruiserweight well that's that's how
about the balls on jake never
jake is not he's got huge balls but also
i don't like anybody criticizing him
have you ever heard him heard of hassan
jr before never no so it doesn't matter
he's a monster it does matter though
because the the you're fighting a guy
tommy fury a much bigger name coming off
the reality show in england yeah his
brother's the most famous boxer on the
planet yeah so there's
there's a reason to buy the paperwork
now short notice find an unknown guy to
be honest
way tougher fight you know what the
psalm junior would do to [ __ ] tommy
nightmare nightmare
nightmare can you bring up some stuff
can i watch some junior like sparring or
moving around yeah but we can't play all
right let's get started
you can't yeah we bring in they're
online we don't need to do it on your
own yeah you guys can box uh yeah what
about the press conference do you have
any interest in seeing that there's a
little four minute like highlight we're
allowed to it's on youtube so i'm kind
of worried okay okay yeah but dude i
mean that that's not i would not let
jake do that for his own good jake jake
has a lot of belief in himself he's a
badass he's way too brave for his own
good i respect all the thing is if i
want to protect if he beats this guy oh
then do you get do you give him credit
is he a boxer now i get a tattoo of jake
paul on my ass if he beats him and i i
become the biggest jake paul fan i go to
every one of his fights i pay all the
money just to get in anywhere close to
the front so i can say i love you jake
because the knock on him is like oh he
only beats up uh mma guys he's never
fought a real boss when they knock on
him anyway he's a badass but he he had a
good point he goes look at canelo look
at floyd mayweather look at tyson fury
look at deonte water look who they're
fighting their sixth fight and look who
i'm fighting dude it's not even
comparable those guys are no jokes his
first five fights are tougher opponents
than any of those guys i mentioned
correctly fights correct but you know
it's just he comes from that youtube
world and he'll be looked at as a
youtuber for who knows how you know it's
tough to beat but he is getting shot he
gets better he trains in earnest he
trains with good guys
i mean boxing's really hard i think one
of the reasons because i thought he's
gonna light uh rahman junior up like
destroy him but he you know he didn't
exactly do that i think he's distracted
because if you've seen what's going on
with him and conor because you know he's
trying to get a fight with connor and
connor just tweeted out something can
you bring up connor's tweet uh chin
connor tweeted out something like
uh like you don't take him serious he's
like it's not happening you're you know
you're a toy dude what are you talking
about
the problem is is conor's not from that
cut of cloth that these young kids are
like jake paul logan paul
remember jake paul started off as a
youtuber so
when you give them
an inch
on anything like you look at jake paul
and dana white david white did a video
directed towards jake paul jake paul
goes oh you want to make videos well i
have my
master's degree in making sizzle videos
check this out i have a crew around me
at all times they can edit and put this
thing up in [ __ ] five minutes it's
gonna destroy anything content you can
put out
so uh connor puts out uh do you have it
here
right now on his instagram uh go to your
email yeah oh yeah i can watch watch it
there now we'll be able to watch jake
paul's yes from video yeah but let's
watch uh what started with connor
because again b you're they're playing a
different game so
jake will win i don't care who you are
maybe another youtuber can hang with him
when it comes to connor dana whoever it
is
nobody's gonna beat jake at what jake
does as far as marketing and creating a
narrative on youtube and social media
he's the best there is the best this is
that's all that's how he got his fame
and his money so when you step into that
pool you better be ready to go when he
says you're a nobody yeah yeah
you're a nobody that's what he said yeah
because so jake paul said so he says
that jake paul cause jake paul was
saying hey there's gonna be a fight
between me and connor and now you can
just play jake so basically all he says
is your nobody it's not happening
and then this is jake paul's rebuttal
conor mcgregor just tweeted at me
because of this interview he has to get
active again you know who knows when
that's gonna happen these are his tweets
and here's my response connor connor
connor you're more active on twitter
than you are in the octagon stop taking
trembolone and start taking fights
you're more actively cheating on your
wife than you are in the octagon your
priorities are mixed up put down the
bottle and get back to fighting you
haven't won a fight in five [ __ ]
years and the last time you did was
against cowboy cerrone who hasn't won a
fight against anyone since fighting you
i'm a nobody you say in this tweet well
yeah you're right i'm just a [ __ ] kid
from ohio i really am a nobody but this
is where you fought your sixth fight
there's literally two people in the
crowd and this is where i'm gonna be
fighting my sixth fight madison square
garden the mecca of boxing august 6 i
know you'll be watching kiddo here's
another fun fact in your 18th fight you
made 150 000 in my fifth fight i made 15
million you want to talk about
pay-per-view buys nate robinson 1.8
million ben askren 500 000 tyrone
woodley won 500 000 tyron woodley 2. no
one even wanted to see that fight and we
got 200 000 pay-per-view buys in the
last five years you've had zero
pay-per-view buys because you don't
[ __ ] fight you have a lot to say
about me but i'm sharing millions of
dollars with underpaid fighters while
you're sharing hookers with dana white
oops i'm sorry connor i know your pr
team is trying to hide that video you
shouldn't have [ __ ] with me connor
this is my game there's a new king in
town i'm running [ __ ] now what's up
connor what's up what's up last year
when i won knockout of the year you were
just getting knocked out fix your
calcium deficiency stop breaking your
bones and let's get in the [ __ ] ring
and make 200 million dollars no matter
how you slice it we're just not on the
same level i'm my own boss yeah you made
100 million dollars when you fought
floyd but dana took half of it so no
matter what you do or what you make cut
that [ __ ] in half we went net worth for
net worth i would [ __ ] on you connor put
the bottle down get off of twitter get
back in the ring and shut the [ __ ] up
i'm going to put you back on a leash
[ __ ] you connor conor mcgregor just
stealing
but these kids have they have no there's
like
everything's offline i hate all that i
hate it too like the reason i hate it
all is because connor has nothing to
prove to anybody that [ __ ] did
it and brought and did everything and
fought all comers well that's why he's
calling them out though
but jake is doing to get on her skin so
that it creates the hype but as far as
like conor sent a tweet and then i'm
telling you you give these young kids
a [ __ ] inch these content creators
where he comes from yeah like dana did
that shitty like dad
facetime video talking [ __ ] to jake
jake's at a party in costa rica drinking
just want his fight he's hanging out
and someone goes hey see what dana does
he watches he goes get the crew together
rips a [ __ ]
hot video about dana beyond cocaine and
all this crazy [ __ ] and fighter pay they
edit it they put in graphics it's up
five minutes later yeah so you just stop
and there's also you're dealing with a
machine somebody said that's all they do
yes it's like getting in the ring with a
black belt when you've never done any
[ __ ] you know like uh
i just i don't even like being that mean
i i like personally like oh that's my
thing with them they're the there's like
the rules of the game these young kids
there is no trying to [ __ ] with
somebody's home they're savages marriage
yeah like to go after somebody's wife
and all this stuff but literally it's
like it's not my gloves are off with
this kid so
you know if you're going to go out for
me i just go oh dude that's like you
know there's no uh there's there there's
i just don't like it i don't like doing
that to anybody but but what's
interesting about this everyone knows i
love jake paul also a huge connor fan
what's interesting about this is it's
interesting that jake's
kind of angle on this is to talk about
pay-per-view buys when connor is bona
fide
the number one pay-per-view draw of all
time in the ufc in combat sports is
involved in the biggest pay-per-view of
all time with him versus floyd so it's
like if he goes you know at 200 000 buys
on this at you know whatever 100 000 and
connor's going dude i'll get 200 000
bucks if i play chess yeah like
like analytically like financially if in
every numerical
comparison you want to make between jake
and connor i know he says i have more
money he doesn't have more money he
doesn't so every
as far as fighting goes
money goes
you're not gonna be connor dude he's the
one guy he can't fight his money on he
won't beat he won't beat connor in a
fight i don't know i'm not even talking
about that much so far i'm not even
talking about that yeah i i don't want
to break that down what i do think is
going to happen though is
you know it's just
dana and you know stan is piped down
like you're not going to beat him at the
video social media
does jake want to box connor or mma him
don't say mma him though either though
you know you sound like you're 90. i
will does he want to mma him well
there's that's why are they going to mma
each other that's my new term i come up
with my own [ __ ] terminology don't
you i'm an older huh you know no i'm not
do you come up do you think this is hip
and you think he's going to be a boxing
thing or is he going to emerge that's a
street talk mma him though yeah that's
street talk that's my new thing now are
you going to mma him are you going to
box him but b tell me this so if you
want to critique you know you don't like
that did you like when connor threw the
doll yet uh
[Music]
i did because he got michael he got
glass in michael's chest his eyes i
don't like that [ __ ] yeah say there's
nobody got hurt nobody actually here's
what i liked about that there's a
difference oh you like that here's what
i like about it
connor i mean khabib slapped artem
artem calls connor connor goes this is
going to be great hype for a fight he
gets all his boys they get on a g7 they
go to [ __ ] in vegas and they messing
square they yeah and they they they
pretend to fight like he he does a whole
theatrical thing throws the thing see
this one i think you're right i don't
think he meant to break the window
that's why i think you're about to
create
i think this is where you're off because
conor
i think the difference between him and
jake is and why
it's not that i'm okay with it i don't
like those crazy antics that he does
outside the octagon
but
to me this is more personal you're
talking about a world-class fighter and
khabib world class fighter and conor and
it was personal yeah conor wasn't like
hey get the camera crew together edit
this thing together and blast it out he
was it he wasn't at all i think that was
a smart publicity stunt though
well the ufc ran with it yeah but notice
no one from conor's team blasted that
out i don't think conor mcgregor because
it went bad i don't i think because it i
thought it didn't go bad i think the
[ __ ] yes but i think that with the glass
in the eye somebody couldn't fight as a
result it became a thing where i was
like oh [ __ ] i think it got a hand but
if he hadn't broken the glass i think
part of that was all a calculated thing
to raise he was always trying to raise
you know the crazy thing you need to see
i think that's where jake and he's not a
good
but that's where jake and connor is
different i think conor it was it was
personal and he wasn't like oh let's do
this get clicks he's too famous so
here's i think connor it was personal
and he went there literally to [ __ ] him
up that was his conor is a fighter's
fighter it was literally to go there and
cause havoc here's nothing he didn't do
it to sell tickets that's the difference
here's my thing also about like so
you're also playing a different game so
jake is going after uh
connor and he's making it personal
don't forget connor makes [ __ ] really
personal he told dustin poirier that his
wife was slipping into his dms he he
kept saying stuff about his wife he he
was really bad about um
muslims yeah and all their father is
family so like connor's getting a taste
of his own medicine and if you're going
to call jake khabib's not going to do
that no jose aldo is not going to do
that no dustin's not going to do that
jake
jake is giving connor a taste of his own
medicine and personally i don't like any
of that like i don't i love trash talk i
just don't like winning it's personal
personal and insulting like really bad
like stuff like personally i think it's
i just don't like that [ __ ] i think it's
classless but yeah we feel bad and we're
old heads but the younger generation is
the younger generation like the and i
think it's a problem like there's no
there's no the fight club rules are
don't exist anymore like the inside
baseball rules where there's rules to
the fight game into baseball that are
unspoken you don't go after people's
family yeah wives girlfriends yeah even
if guy has side pieces that's right you
don't talk about that and that's right
that's how it should be it's called
decency it's called there has to be some
rules
exactly and so these kids lost the rules
because they're getting clicked yeah the
younger generation is wrong about that
agree 100 yeah they're wrong about it
and that's where maybe older people come
in and go this is wrong i know it's
shiny and you're going to swallow it but
there's a hook on that and and and but
showtime's not doing that show time like
even showtime commented on his thing it
was like oh you know like
everybody just they know they're getting
clicks they know this it's going to
equal pay-per-views or you know it's
going to add to their investment just so
we know that when you do things for
money and only money there's a there's a
word for that it's called being a [ __ ]
so people have the like so people always
like have this thing about hookers and
she's a prostitute you're you're a
prostitute too bro if you've done a job
just for money and i have you're a [ __ ]
i've been a whole and you can feel it
you're selling yourself i've been a
[ __ ] when you're doing a gig for money
like [ __ ] dude what am i doing that's
why it's never worth it never ever never
you marry somebody for money you marry
for your friends oh you're paying for it
you're professing somebody for influence
paying for it yeah yeah it's all lies
you're a [ __ ]
um but i but to go back to the main
point i do think that's why jake was a
little off in that press conference
because his focus was on connor he did
that hot promo on connor he's there and
i didn't think he thought hussein jr was
gonna go hard in the paint and was ready
to go so he's like oh [ __ ] he's just
am i wrong i felt like he was a little
off he there was a few points that
uh haseem brought up that jake didn't
really seem to have a response like
so i see the whole thing yeah the the
main points i would say that he kept
hammering
were
um
your team told you to go
that i couldn't do southpaw i could only
box with one he kept saying uh
i could only fight you with one arm i
could only fight you with one hand right
they wouldn't let me go southpaw and you
were running from me in the ring when i
backed you up in the corner you were
running for me and there was just a few
moments where
uh jake kind of was like okay we'll see
yeah i'll put out the footage and then
haseem was like put out the footage
put it out like he didn't seem scared of
putting out the footage now normally
jake has a response for every single
thing so he's usually in my mind almost
but it's funny because now i'm thinking
i'm like
that makes me want to see the fight more
you know what i mean i'm like oh like so
it's almost like a reverse
building the fight where it's like
if you don't respond everything and
don't correct him or whatever like
it's almost like you're building up like
ooh maybe he does something have
something i think
i don't think jake is scared i don't
think you know he would have took the
fight if you
if they keep marketing like this i think
it does good on pay-per-view better than
his last fight yeah because the haters
of jake paul are going to tune in to
seem loose because this is
by far his toughest matchup so it's kind
of the floyd mayweather effect like
floyd's like listen i don't care if you
hate or like love me as long as you buy
the pay-per-view that's all you're
[ __ ] about i don't want to be in the
middle right same with comics any comics
in the middle they never sell tickets
yeah either great hater you want hate
and love you don't want to be the guy in
the middle trying not to hate or love
baby yeah that's how you start talking
about it you'll be undeniable yeah i
wonder if two because that's why i think
this can do well because i think people
like oh [ __ ] this guy beat up jake
before i think jake should acknowledge
like yeah dude i was it was three years
ago i wasn't training like i came now
yeah you what my ass we'll see what
happens august 6 yeah and that's the
narrative and also yeah you whip my ass
but i guarantee you're not gonna do it
it must be exhausting to constantly have
to be fighting it must be exhausting to
always in conflict yeah for me i seem
tired that was the main thing i was like
he seemed like he was like kind of like
you could interpret it that way like
you're just kind of like
yeah dude i'm tired from training
i don't see how people do it you know
the people that just always live in that
toxic like and they want conflict all
the time yeah like if we're in conflict
i'm on conflict with somebody else
another personality whatever i'm like oh
this is the way if jake said that [ __ ]
about me and i was gonna fight him my
feelings would get hurt so bad i'd be
like i don't know how to talk trash i'm
not i'm not good at roasting i don't i
don't i always feel bad vicious no
matter what
even if i see an opening to roast
somebody always makes me feel uh like
i'm hurting their feelings i [ __ ] it
depends what the game is it's a
personality type thing though because i
used to think i don't think jake is a
sociopath but like he was initially
framed that way in the media
i'm like oh because he does like
you could he just he's a positive value
set and that's fine he's a product of
his mind yeah but like his i think his
inherent personality there's a level of
ruthlessness especially when it comes to
verbal conflict that he's willing to go
to and i admire that because i think
like if you're gonna step into that
arena you like with other people talking
trash to you like you just want to win
at any cost so like i admire it in a way
because it is like trolling and talking
[ __ ] is an art form and he's really good
at it but like he transgresses the
boundaries of different generations i
think
um what admire about the paul kids the
paul brothers they work there they are
disciplined they come from that ohio
farm yeah he backs up all the boys
savage i mean jake's hard good but logan
as far as businesswise savage yeah yeah
fake too though yeah so it's like
logan is ruthless in a different way i'm
sure but jake expresses that in trash
talk which not everyone wants to kind of
reveal their own psychology through you
know because it's like ooh once you say
certain things you're like i know where
your mind goes those guys are those guys
seem very close as brothers yeah they're
very close to each other's back yeah big
time and i think that for jake probably
jake for probably a while when he was
growing up might have been uh in the
shadow a little bit about his brother's
master yeah still is but
so for jake it's like he's got some [ __ ]
to prove he's got that's a chip that you
don't lose like logan's not gonna fight
this guy or tommy fury to try to be a
legit fighter like logan's gonna do the
mike tyson thing or you know the ksi
thing like he's he's just doing it for
the the
the fame and the money he's doing wwe
jake is legit his desires to get
validation from the fight community i
listen i if he knocks his team junior
out in five seconds i still don't think
they give it up to him it's [ __ ]
tough dude i believe you know they're
just not due like
when he was calling out michael bisping
he came to my show at the improv i went
bubba you're going the wrong way you're
calling a legend dude and he has one eye
and he's retired he's got one leg in one
eye well i told him well really one eye
and i said he has one eye and i said
he's retired dude you're not gonna get
the respect of our fan base doing that i
said you wanna get attention and get
validation and you to stay in the mma
world call anderson silva currently
fighting just beat julio chavez jr legit
dude he's one of the goats and he's
active don't call out the guy with one
eye who's in broadcasting you're we're
not going to get you're not going to get
our respect no because you're picking up
you're being a bully with anderson
you're going to get bullied
you know what i'm saying like he beat
julio chavez junior fight you're right
he'll fight you right now right now yeah
now did you see uh jake go on andrew
schultz and talk about i thought this
was an interesting conversation
uh whether or not he'd fight his brother
he said something unexpected he goes the
parents don't want him to do it um
there's a history of brothers not facing
each other like klitschko brothers he
gave some other examples she'll promise
their mom they'd never [ __ ] yeah but
he goes he ends he sets that all up
because mom says we should never do it
um dad like yeah mom and dad and this
history of he goes but
we make history so he's i'm like oh
you're right oh you could do this the
first day ever you missed the bread and
shop food truck logan paul three years
ago where he was getting ready to fight
floyd and we're talking about that and
whatever all that nonsense and i go the
the money fight is you versus your
brother and he goes well now you're
asking the right questions i know you
fight your brothers yeah for the right
thing he goes and i think that'd be the
ultimate goal we're both on our own path
to get to each other he goes then it'd
be our own promotion jake versus logan
he's like that's how this ends and the
final thing yeah
he goes um
i'm okay doing that he goes i've i'm i
can accept if i well
there's this one little dynamic he goes
i'm okay with getting locked knocked out
by logan paul but i'm the little brother
he would have a much harder time living
the rest of his life
if and he goes and this is the more
likely scenario just kind of based on
our records he doesn't want to fight you
know so he's doing like i don't know
he's like i just let's be real i think
jake i think jake beats logan yeah
correct really it was an interesting
little goat because he's going to have a
heart attack because he loses
jake has that fighter's mean streak
which to me when i saw him fight and to
be i'll be completely honest always i've
always been a fan of him i'm way closer
with his his brother logan i love logan
with jake i was always kind of you know
on and off and then i was in miami doing
shows and uri hall was in the hotel it
was right when jake was about to fight
ben askren
and uriah and i are talking about i go
dude but you think about ben he's been
in the world champions didn't get
knocked out and your eye goes stop dude
he goes i'm not a huge jake paul fan
have you seen him spar and i haven't
seen he goes look look at this he had
some footage whatever he goes look at
this movement he showed to me i was like
oh sh that's jacob's
yes he can move he's an athlete
he's an athlete when you say both
brothers are athletes 100 yeah yeah but
when you're actually saying i'm telling
you listen i want i want [ __ ] um
ben asking to win too because you know
alumni with us and i go yeah that's why
i write for ben he goes it ain't
happening man he's i'm telling you see
this kid and teddy his time he goes he
was what's alarming is his timing for
only fighting this long his timing is
boom boom knocking dudes out sparring
partners that's hard and he showed me
that team like oh
[ __ ] he's also sparring real dudes in
the gym yeah yeah
he's a big strong kid man i think it's
interesting though and boxing has never
been bigger you know what
the fastest growth they've had i would a
lot of that you've got to give up to
jake paul who else would you give it to
i agree who else earl spence yeah
terence crawford he's the only one
jay paul might be making everybody
richer in the fight game oh yeah he's
changing the fight game so well there's
a reason why nate and connor and all
these guys are up for it yeah there's a
reason
there's a reason for all that but i just
find interesting too that jake if you're
if you're going to talk about
pay-per-view buys and money the one guy
you can't put in a corner and pick on
for money and paper you buys is con you
can't flex your money on conor mcgregor
remember he said 1.8 million at the
start and i go i was looking that up i'm
like oh wait that was tyson roy jones jr
headlining that though yes you can't
really say you did the 1.8 no part of it
but counters the biggest pay-per-view
draw
yes yeah so it's all time i don't know
that yeah it's weird right
wow you talk about his whiskey and floyd
like and he's
they didn't take 50 percent but then
oscars whiskey's like i think they sold
for a billion dollars or more yeah he
they it was reporting made 400 million
i know connor's team pretty well
made more than that so like you don't
you don't want to play that game with
when it comes to money it's just you're
talking about a different animal so like
you don't want to compare preview
numbers and financial numbers with you
just connor's not the guy to do it
you know it's just it's just a weird
game
but then when it comes to personal [ __ ]
and doing these you know ripping these
videos it's
dana and no staying a pipe down
because when jake was like jake was like
bro i have all the money i'll fight for
free as long as you give fighters health
insurance and pay them correctly i'll
fight whoever you want
and dan was like i'm good
you know
yeah i think uh there's there's a lot i
like about jake paul a lot you should
almost
all of what i like because because
whether or not you uh i'm uneasy with
his talk i'm uneasy when he's mean like
i think he's because we're all it makes
me uneasy jay hates it too i just don't
like he goes i don't like the trolling
no it's not but i like him i think he's
a special dude and i think his brother's
great too
i think these are young men that are
growing up and becoming men and jake was
like i want to do something that peop
everybody says is impossible it's
[ __ ] really scary and really hard to
get good at boxing let me tell you when
you when you have to go spar every day
and you're going to get your [ __ ]
head kicked in
every single day you have butterflies
every day your days are there's much
together doesn't need to do it it's the
same with like paige van zandt it's
incredible her only fan she said bubba
yeah she has all the movie offers in the
world she said she she's fighting
[ __ ] was it august uh i'm doing
[ __ ] me august uh
uh 20th 19th i respect it
she has no reason to do but they just
love the fight jake could film himself
playing checkers and make money yep he
they don't need to do this he could keep
making youtube i think people dislike
people like that because those they they
set an example of what courage is and
how they just that i love that
expression that nobody's proud of you
they're just surprised you keep making
[ __ ] happen right you know what i said
to you bubba that's a good quote it's
true it is and she just keeps moving
forward okay yeah i know she might lose
i know that you can say whatever you
want she keeps doing it yeah you have to
respect that someone's going to willing
to risk the embarrassment when they
don't need to if it's a young fighter it
doesn't have anything came from you know
the gutters and that's the way they're
going to make choices i get it when
someone has all the money and choices
and doesn't need to do it he goes no i'm
still going to dedicate however many
weeks to this training camp
hustle i respect hustle i respect
like when you see somebody who stays
strong and you can see their ribs like i
respect the [ __ ] out of that it's ballsy
to do that it's ballsy to do with jacob
i know you're not paying attention to it
i'll say i have to in my world but uh
dana white's getting [ __ ] right now
because he gave the elk boys who i don't
know if people know this but the elk
boys are in cahoots with the ufc right
milky ways are huge youtubers the ufc
went how can we stay young and get the
young demo no boys here's however much
money they gave them
you know come to ufc events create ufc
content be best buddies with dana go on
the shows all that [ __ ] they also do the
same with bar stool right so whoever's
doing this smart smart play how can we
keep dana relevant right he's the most
famous guy in the ufc keep them relevant
link him up with these young youtubers
get that young fan base over to the ufc
so they're doing the right moves it's a
little weird but you can see it from a
mile away
so the neck boys who we have same
business measure like if i told you the
numbers the money they make just off the
merchant you'd [ __ ] want to start my
feelings it hurt everybody's feeling
yeah
for his i think birthday or whatever he
gives him 250 000 cash
now i don't have a problem with it
danny created the ufc turned into two
billion dollar company he makes all the
money in the world right he gave the
knock boys who have all the money
already so he gave him 250 thousand
dollars yes every fighter you know got
on there and was like bro i made 50 000
for fight of the night you're giving her
another near who has who's broke you're
giving you're given the knuckles you
already financially set 250 000 as a
gift cash
so basically 500 grand cash after taxes
250.
so the fighter is all upset about it and
you know remember danny used to post him
gambling and he'd put whatever 100 on a
hand on a hundred thousand dollars on
blackjack after the fights break dude
you're being a hundred thousand dollars
a hand you're giving fifty thousand to
five the night these guys lost brain
cells and you're playing with a hundred
thousand dollars if i'm dana i go yeah
start your own league
yeah i took all the risk i came up with
all the ideas
turned two billion dollar company
sleepless nights had all the brains
behind it go fight for somebody else yep
you know but it's like should 100
percent that he should pay guys more
and notice i stopped talking about
fighter pages i don't know their
overhead i don't know the ins and outs
of it but i've always said operating
system i said i don't know how to run
that i don't know i don't know exactly
so you notice i don't talk about it
clearly it can be paid more than pay
whatever 17 clearly be paid more so the
backlash for dana when he gets another
mega millionaire 250 thousand dollars is
triggering to the fighters i get it al
joe peter yan tj dilla like these guys
like dude that's fair
i'd be pissed too
you know i i don't know it kind of yes
or no if i'm dating like
well you guys are upset about what start
your own league yeah you think this was
all fun and games for me sure to turn
two billion dollar company you know the
amount of [ __ ] i've had to do for the
past however since [ __ ]
2004 years almost yeah
for you know
i know it's it's it's uh i i see both
sides you're allowed to do whatever you
want with your money um
the ufc is growing
or not internationally there
i'd say in the states
not so much yeah internationally that'll
come out so so but they just had their
biggest year ever they'll have to yeah
they'll they'll whatever they're doing
they're gonna have to figure out there's
always a challenge it's a constant it's
a verb it's always changing you're
always adjusting you're always trying to
make differences you know that's that's
how it is so
[ __ ] i'm going to be in milwaukee guys
july 21 22-23 i just want to say that
out loud and then i'll be in austin the
following weekend with us yes it doesn't
matter now listen what fort wayne i said
hey if this doesn't sell well daddy's
probably i heard you sold
some crazy amount of tickets we're
almost sold on every show they're
talking about adding shows in fort wayne
indiana in the summer daddy shout out to
fort wayne india my boys that run
spokane comic club bricks down comedy
club the best in the business they've
always told me they've never stirred me
wrong you got to come to fort wayne in
july i'm like dude this summer
inflation's be a nightmare and i have to
take 17 different planes to get there
yeah they sent me the ticket sales
yesterday oh
oh we have 50 tickets left to sell we're
going to city we sell 50 we sold 1500
tickets in fort wayne indiana
i need to sell tickets so fort wayne you
goddamn savages not only am i coming
back i'm always coming back
always
and then next week i'm in san diego
thursday friday saturday that's the
laugh factory san diego with a very
special guest that's lap factory heart
of san diego downtown laugh factory get
you some i filmed the paddy pimlet food
truck there um so and then i also
featured deleah there that club is
ridiculous being it's such a [ __ ]
good room i gotta call enrique but that
so it's uh so this week 50 tickets left
for all shows in fort wayne indiana at
the summit comedy club out there in fort
wayne indiana and then next week is uh
san diego laugh factory tickets at
thickboy.com
and this new merch drops as well i think
in a week or two donuts we got this in
uh the long white tee and then we got
tanks and we got a new uh trucker hat
coming out ooh sammy the bull best of
drops tomorrow
best up with brian callan on youtube
sammy the bulls one of the guys i'm
pumped about that those episodes we got
episode one and then it's to be
continued episode two it'll be the
following week so it drops uh on
thursday on thursday tomorrow
we're dropping it what time you get
dropping you know i will drop it always
release same day same time try to do it
every day same day same time you have to
yeah like noon on thursday
i think what do you think is a good time
to drop
um
if you have it i'd rather you drop it
early in the week so because people will
consume that stuff
at work and during the week so driving
on thursday it's going to die off on
friday afternoon texting with rogan
today about uh
about [ __ ] shooting pigs in austin
now joe's only going to be well yeah i
got to find he hasn't killed any pigs in
austin i want to kill some pigs in the
austin area if anybody knows for my for
my show i'm going to talk to tim kennedy
i will but tim's not in the country
jim's tim might be something hey you're
freedom welcome that's you know what i'm
saying so i gotta i'll text him don't
know if he's gonna get back can we get
back to me it depends if he's in the
states he gets back like this
and then sometimes if it's two weeks i
went oh daddy's yeah you know he's doing
it didn't you text him
you just got you just got a picture of
the american flag on his uniform
somewhere with like with like desert in
the background no no no no he was in a
blackhawk helicopter in full gear okay
and i went say less text on your back be
safe
i would love to be able to do that just
text hey
want to have dinner this weekend just
[ __ ] picture goggles [ __ ] sh
[Music]
no i would do a video
nope
no not even that you just go like this
just shake your head he's so goddamn
american
his his yeah we brought it up last time
but his
his tweet about our tweeter instagram
post on uh brittany griner he was like
this person has talked [ __ ] about
america and blah blah and he goes and
even with that i still want to go out
and save her and get her back to america
then lebron's dumb ass on his hbo show
goes if i'm brittany griner i wouldn't
want to come back to america the way
they're treating her i wouldn't come
back to this country
lebron
i can't you
before
all you know like over the lockdown
stuff and all that and the the protests
before all this stuff and this stuff
about not coming back to america you're
talking me and my brother would fight
about lebron james what fight you want
my favorite he was my favorite i can't
stand this dude now really can't stand
it really i threw away all my lebrons i
have the first lebrons that are worth
throwing
i don't [ __ ] with them
when that cop when he didn't know what
the [ __ ] he was talking about they put
out your times come and release his
address and put a clock like a tick like
to go after this cop
who defended a black woman saved a black
woman's life and had to shoot an uh the
remember that remember the
one black one is trying to stab the
other one yes top gets or goes put down
the knife she's trying to kill the other
black woman yeah he shoots her yeah and
lebron tweets out enough enough his
address and then a time emoji like we're
coming for you i went
oh i'm out i'm out dude wow i'm out you
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
he should now he redacted that it was
like i didn't look i didn't get enough
look at the details
the power that you have to tweet that
out are you out of your [ __ ] mind
dangerous it's very dangerous for cops
yeah do you think
it's inciting violence you could have
had that cop killed who was who was
saving a black woman but then remember
that cop which was hilarious put out
that video you remember you pretend to
talk to lebron yes he got like suspended
yeah yeah i think he got fired it was
hilarious at that remember that yes and
he ended with uh mj's better he goes
what nothing have a good day click
so my comfortable shop regarding
brittany grant so this is him because
he's got so much background she's
probably feeling emotionally along with
so many other emotions
you know it's when you're him and you
say one thing people freak out
don't give them a pass [ __ ] no dude
because if you have a history of doing
this one time
yeah i'll you people can make you're not
trusting careful people i'm very
forgiving you know this yes people make
mistakes i'm all good dude yeah when you
have lebron james platform and you put
out a hit on a cop right mistake number
one and the rest of [ __ ] you're
spewing out pretend to carry books to
pretend to be educated and read that you
know anything about what the [ __ ] you're
talking about and the reporter goes
you've brought that book to like seven
different games it's the bookmark still
on the the second page you asked him
about it or he goes what's your favorite
part i love reporters sometimes
reporters are [ __ ] awesome
or what how about the report goes oh
what are you reading it's the it's the
uh the biography of malcolm x what's
your favorite about malcolm x that's how
you know he's reading he goes
all of it
it was the most that was that was me in
ninth grade that's nice because
you know
you know what about it that was when
they asked me about my favorite thing
about boo radley
all of it
to the
the teacher would go
teacher just goes oh you clearly didn't
read any of it but you thought you were
passionate
that was me all day
man where do i start what's your
favorite yeah who's here one time
we're like they're asking us about
politics you weren't following politics
back then guy goes who would you vote
for and you go
ah it's tough
yeah i was like not not the good news no
no no you people wouldn't smell them
that's lebron
like if you're gonna be about it educate
yourself and be about it and stand up
for yourself but be educated on it yeah
but when you're buying into social media
and you think this is what people want
you to stick up for but you don't know
you're actually hurting the customers
actually showing why america where this
a lot of other place a lot of other
cultures and places look up to their
celebrities and athletes as
you know they get their opinions and
advice from them america really doesn't
no we don't no i'm go [ __ ] what brad
pitt wants to vote i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't care what he is i'm not looking
for guidance on him when it comes to
politics and inflation
you know what
not your expertise no i don't want to
hear that yeah who was it who said uh uh
jeff died i thought it was so funny he
posted he goes why are all the guys high
on nfts and [ __ ] uh crypto uh why do
they all have three roommates or still
own skateboards in their forties
[ __ ] so true it's like
uh everybody who i know has made a lot
of money that when they talk about
crypto they go i i'm gonna play around a
little bit sometimes we'll see i'm not
i'm not a fan
i'm watching yeah
oh yeah
what's bitcoin at right now
19k 19k was it 50. 60. it was up to 60.
yeah and it's in 19k
like crypto and all that like you
realize the government especially when
china was like this ain't happening yeah
and the government's like hold on you
guys want to do this free market with
the government you want to fight well
like this one guy said they're one
regulation away from having it just
completely go away now i don't know
because they're the i like the idea in
the concept i just know that the
government we said this same with bull
always wins
they're way smarter than us they're not
gonna let you come up with this new form
of currency and transaction and not have
their beaks get wet you're gonna they
have the biggest they're
they're pelicans and when i say what
they're beats that means they're going
to eat all of it and control it that's
right yeah and you're going to invest
all your money while carrying it you're
not going to replace the dollar
well never yeah because all the the the
big boys here that run america all the
big boys go ah yeah
69k was the high down to 19. wow pretty
crazy well
if you're in crypto like bitcoin it's a
long play right 10 years but yeah um now
if you bought it when you started i mean
i remember the craze when it was up to
1700 in like 2014. remember when i first
started that guy paid uh for two cheese
pizzas he gave like 60 kryptos and then
when i was out time high they're like
sir you paid
[ __ ] yeah whatever it was like yeah
transaction i've made since 2012
yeah i'd be a billionaire
that's okay though all right jane i got
about 15 minutes give some current
events dude
give us a food truck with a powerful
michael chandler oh flew michael
chandler wow
is he coming here a day notice
is he here
uh i think his eta is like 145 150.
the marvin victoria won't drop you know
marvin victoria
number three middleweight in the world
no i know he is but yeah great guy man
is he yeah i was worried about his
intelligent italian awesome
so i was at uh the calabasas like
pumpkin night you know with my kids last
halloween they have food trucks there
there's this food truck that's
you've never seen anything like it
double decker lights
blind was [ __ ] seven miles long i
just took a picture of it send the kc
books all through drago find out who
this is you've never seen a food truck
like this
but let's make sure we save for a
special guest
casey a few weeks ago oh i talked to the
that pizza food truck that you saw in
calabasas are curious it tells me how
much i'm like holy [ __ ] that's how much
that is for that truck is yeah man
they're big time so let's save for a
special guest reach out to marvin oh hey
dude you want to do food triggers
absolutely i'm in uh huntington beach
i'll drive down there you know i don't
need travel or anything if you want to
cover my gas all good so i'm like all
right well this and he goes my but he
goes i'm about to start camp because he
fights in uh he fights robert whittaker
in paris france wow uh in september wow
or maybe august but september he goes
i'm about to start camp and i can have
one cheat meal i want good pizza so i
call i go dude we're saving on the
travel and all that [ __ ] so we're gonna
do
uh that pizza truck hit him up marvin
wants good pizza this pizza truck is the
biggest baddest there is let's do that
so we got that pizza truck for marvin he
gets there the trucks all dope and
everything the name he goes dude that's
actually real italian because usually
americans [ __ ] it up they think it's
italian it's not and he he said the name
is beautiful when he says it so we get
there
and i look in there and you know you
can't tell these guys were like dark
skinned like olive skin i know you guys
from uh italy huh and he goes no man
mexican
uh
what he was yeah we're making uh jose
back there in mexico
oh oh but the owner i'm sure he's
telling us i'm mexican dude
how do you give a target i'm sorry man
is that cultural appropriation i looked
i looked down between you i'm so sorry
how was the people how was the pizza
it was good okay
there you go i liked it it was good it
was solid yeah it's hard to impress an
italian you know it's like i'm not
talented i wasn't impressed yeah that's
like louise you are food connoisseurs
okay it's joking i'm a little bit louie
i'm a little racist i mean you know like
if i if i'm looking for pizza i walk in
and three black women are making my
pizza i'll be like
okay
all right maybe i'll just take another
walk down there yeah yeah
here you go uh
what's this
south african man
dead after downing an entire bottle of
jagermeister in two minutes well why is
that guy shooting somebody just
they do that all the time on
died tuesday after you allegedly drank
an entire bottle jagermeister it was a
game that was part of a drinking
challenge now you guys wouldn't do that
would you but why did he die how did you
die from that
it racked up 9 000 views i mean that's
not that insane tohan
guzzled uh entire bottle of yield that
kills you alcohol poisoning i guess
in that quick of a time depending on
your body just can't filter out all the
alcohol you might already have a
condition
uh can i just see uh
have been competing against other
customers at a liquor store in the
machamba village to down a bottle of
liquor to win about 12 that's the real
piece of the story there is
you know imagine doing that for 12 bucks
that's a bummer you couldn't get me to
take a shot of you i hate you jaeger's
also has so much sugar too
disgusting what person actually likes
that flavor i had a buddy in college
chad uh custworth loved he had a jaeger
machine
but there's so much sugar in jager
really oh i like it bringing up the
sugar and jaeger's nut subs
yeah yeah the flavor is like black
licorice right is that what it is yeah
and i love black licorice that's the
english but i don't like jager
interesting
don't do drinking games because we
always hear about every year
like
so six grams of shot
it's not terrible but
if you do enough of them sure you know
let's say you do four shots four times
24 grams of sugar a lot well but that's
what a lot of times what you're hanging
over so bad if you're drinking really
sugary drinks mixed with alcohol yeah it
intensifies your hangout yep
science what else you got
facts
college
what's this here's an interesting one
they the guys at espn
um
mistaken
mistakenly quoted this during a segment
uh on this just in do you know the show
so
they mis uh attributed a quote to john
warren uh
john moran john moran yeah
tells you how much you know about
basketball if you put mj in today's game
he's just another superstar the fake
quote which was liked over 25 000 times
on twitter red um wait i'm sorry so him
saying mj would just be another
superstar as a fake question yes
on ball sack sports i guess that's the
funny part of it it's like i'm confused
though uh mark so
he didn't say that so he don't say that
if you put mj in today's game he's just
another superstar we got me steph luca
dame trey and then guys like lebron
katie giannis kawaii it's not just one
superstar and a bunch of you know
average dudes yeah that's a fake he said
that he didn't say that that's all made
up wow why don't they make that up they
didn't it's just this must just be a
fake you know ball sack sports it's just
like a parody like oh wow you know
account but they just played out he
absolutely did not say this in this
interview i can't believe you guessed
that he did there should be a correct
yeah that's not 100 percent and then so
they took that you guys know john marant
no
bro
so good so the dunk in the in the
playoffs stupid really oh my god dude
he's so [ __ ] tough that's him right
there with that he's not and he's not
huge and my god is he good at oh he's
not that big no my dude he dunks on
people
hard he's so entertaining just plays in
a small market so he's not getting a ton
of breaths he plays for memphis uh uh
you see on instagram these guys with
50-inch vertical leaps i never used to
see that i remember when 42 inches was
crazy now you see the 50-inch vertical
leaves are you is that are those
skeptical hippo eyes yes they are yes
because i'm seeing crazy crazy not
instagram too much but what's going on
that's all fake who who who's saying
it's 50.
they see these guys touching you see
these guys doing the you know when you
touch the i don't know what the [ __ ] you
guys do in the combines and stuff to see
where your vertical is
they're getting up there like on a level
where you're like what the [ __ ] is going
on these kids are dunking five eight
dunkin like their heads hit is that the
rim yeah
i mean i'm not web kid you're talking
about in the 80s dude no
that this is
web dunk yes but this is weird yeah
yeah there's a video of it yeah this guy
daniel cabaya
um there's an asian guy there's this
chinese guy who's jumping like [ __ ]
crazy 50's unheard of probably gonna be
short like because the five nine you
know guy does it so it's like yeah
you're probably not gonna get a seven
footers anyone overseas they said they
said jordan's was like
40
i forget like mid-40s yeah 46 47 yeah
great freak yeah freaked yeah
yeah
what about the brian urlacher one oh
yeah
there you go
brian erlacker
says that some ex-nfl players claim to
have cte
to be in the lawsuit
do you guys yeah why wouldn't you right
but i'm sure and here's the other thing
because if they're gonna chill out all
this money for the former players right
yeah there's no way to prove it we have
no way of proof there's no test to prove
while you're alive right no no they have
you have to die and then they look
inside your brain yeah so if they gave
you the cte test now and there's money
on the line what would you do to fake
having cte
just what i'm doing i've made so many
mistakes talking on the podcast
they're just i just
have you edit all the times i've [ __ ]
up
somebody said something somebody said
something really interesting that i've
thought about a lot lately
people always say please
because i thought
oh no you're gonna [ __ ] up no matter
what yeah you can just put that together
yeah yeah you're [ __ ] this is a
totally thing on this guy but people
always look back and they go well i
would have done this differently i would
have done different definitely like and
then somebody said everything's a
trade-off like
doing a podcast was a great idea for us
over the past 10 years yeah overall
great idea yeah saved my life yes there
are things you could have done other
than this we could have been outside
more we could have been working on
something says
anything you do you're going to give
something up for something else if
you're in a place there might be other
way there might be other things you can
do but the idea that you look back and
say what would i have done wrong i think
you would have just made this different
mistakes
you would have made different mistakes
and you would have different it's an
alternate timeline any line any any
field you chose to go in you're making
no one's going to be perfect in any
field with somebody you're talking about
having regrets and you're like my life
would be better had i chose this other
thing be like well
not necessarily
it sounds like you know what i'm not
even
this is an arrogance thing i've that's
that has never crossed my mind well no
me neither i've been kissing ever
because i chose to be a comic thank god
i chose to be an actor thank god chose
being so where does this come from well
the idea is some people like i remember
i don't know anybody i remember i said i
want to be an actor
and i remember
everyone in my life who wanted to
protect me the closest people said
you're crazy
don't [ __ ] but that's in it but then
welcome to the world but i could have
listened and i could have said yeah
you're right this is a fool's errand and
i wouldn't have done it and i don't know
who i would have been right
but
i'm just saying one more card today you
do
i mean but that's anything like anything
they can write like it's not all your
hallmark just listen but no i'm just
saying be like but anything like family
wants to protect you so it's like i'm be
a professional fighter i'm being an
actor but people i'm gonna be follow
that impulse a lot of times and they pay
for it the rest of their life you have
to
[ __ ] sometimes but that's the only
person who knows the answer but that's
the difference be like you have to have
that self belief like yeah because i if
if you're let's say you're starting
comedy or a ufc career now and you put a
a pull up on instagram said hey how many
think i should start a career in
stand-up or ufc you think it's going to
be
90 yeah go for it no dude you're going
to get horrible stories no don't do that
it's too tough blah blah blah i would
say that to my own kids i'd be like oh
you know let's get sensible yeah do you
know anybody that lives in regrets
though like that like who fixates on
their regrets because like i think it's
okay to have like thoughts like that but
as long as you don't stay there because
it's such a waste productive yeah it's
such a waste of time waste of [ __ ]
time because what are you gonna do
there's nothing to do tell the truth
tell yourself the truth yeah you got to
you got to start by telling yourself the
truth
and it's really easy not to
you know that elon musk said the big the
biggest thing i i suffer from um then
this is him saying it and what i noticed
a lot of people suffer from is wishful
thinking you know that [ __ ] there you go
that'll work out or you know it's like
oh we'll figure it out hold on no you
won't hold on
things don't just work out on their own
a lot of times you've got to make good
choices yeah yeah
what did you get jen
this one
yeah so okay
wait there was another thing that i saw
that you that was another current event
that i wanted this one i want to ask
about
yeah who is tony shariko uh paulie
walnuts
so he just died and yeah they live
streamed his funeral oh [ __ ] um the guy
with the streak in his hair exactly
pulley ball nuts he's i mean what a
great character huh wait let me let me
make sure i know who he is born in 1942
yeah 79
yeah he's exactly what you're thinking
of the guy with the he was actually they
say he was actually for a while in the
mob right or wasn't he you believe it
don't you i mean yeah hell yeah
like all those characters were saying oh
he was great
yeah but such a memorable character on
the show full of memories oh he's great
let me see something
was pulling them up army invention and
tony stark managed to accumulate more
than 80 accredited but he'll always
remember his mind
yeah he was so good so he was an actor
he wasn't yeah 80 acting credits pretty
good it was great pretty good imdb great
what a great career
uh do you love the sopranos guys
this would be like the best show ever
the best shows ever yeah yeah
what else you got jen
here we go
what do you guys got
well
gen z says siren gays can trick horny
men into getting whatever you want so
now tick tockers are coaching women on
the exact look that you can use
to manipulate and exploit men
um it's called the siren gaze trend
um where women are claiming a slight
upturn of their lips is what seals a
deal with potential partners
she doesn't have to do that that's the
siren
siren yeah yeah so i guess that's
and a lot of plastic surgery yeah
it'd also be a 10.
yeah
yeah i mean she's not starting yeah
master your saturday sirens is gays yeah
i don't need any sirens yeah yeah you
could actually be wearing a bag over
your head and i go wait
who is that that body it's crazy you
know yeah you could be in a biden shirt
i'd still be attracted yeah
and so okay what do you think about the
ethics of this you know
i mean you know women have been is this
any different than getting fake breasts
or makeup being in shape makeup dressing
well peacocking a little bit yeah guys
do it too it's just another thing to
sell now you can sell a
here's how gays should look i'll teach
you how to breathe i'll teach you how to
gaze you know
you always you always gotta come with
some new kind of angle monetize
everything yeah monetize everything is
that it guys
there it is ladies and gentlemen there
it is work on your gays fellas watch out
for this milwaukee next weekend
tomorrow
sammy the bull episode one austin texas
cap city is july 28 29 30 nashville
tennessee's 80s august 26 27 spokane
washington it's number 22 23 24 brennan
where are you going to be uh this week
we got 50 tickets left for a complete
sell out in fort wayne indiana bay bay
summit comedy club in fort wayne indiana
that is this thursday friday saturday
the thick squad will be there uh next
wednesday night 10 p.m show hollywood
improv shop and friends some monsters
and then also next week thursday friday
saturday i'm in san diego my favorite
places in the world san diego laugh
factory downtown san diego come get you
some august 4th through the 6th i'm in
baltimore one night only in chicago at
the den theater that is a 7 30 show one
show only i'm at the den theater in
chicago heart of chicago and then the
next day on the 27th is the tough mudder
right outside chicago so come to the
comedy show on 26 and join me and my
friends at rain and um the tough mudder
mark will be there a bunch of think boy
boys will be there you can sign up using
the promo code team brendan you save i
think 10 off on the sign up fee i think
my heat is at 10 a.m it's limited
capacity
uh so make sure you sign up right now
that's august 27th toughmotor.com but
the 26 is the den theater in chicago and
then you'll see the rest of the dates on
there all right guys but uh fort wayne
indiana fifth or 50 tickets are left
baby let's sell this [ __ ] out um that's
this thursday friday saturday san diego
you're up next week love you guys be
good show just a fun kid we're out